you ready I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
it will kill
Daya
developed into Italy during the
Renaissance the Cinque DEA gained
popularity among civilian noblemen this
large double-edged sword delivered
lethal Cuts in Close Quarter attacks and
was worn on the hip to be swiftly drawn
in times of threatening encounters
derived from the Italian word for the
number five the name chingwadea
represents the blade measuring five
fingers wide at the base which became an
excellent canvas for intricate artwork
with functionality in mind swordsmiths
also included Fullers to lighten the
weight of this otherwise heavy sword
although the chingwood Daya lost its
popularity after the 16th century it has
recently made a comeback in the video
game Assassin's Creed the Cinco Deo was
used for civilian dress but it served
one purpose
a kill I will take your weapon and
deliver killing blows to this big
carcass
Daniel up first you ready yes sir I'm a
little concerned when I see how well
constructed Neil's blade is but I've got
a 50 50 chance of winning either God
wills it or God doesn't
[Music]
all right Dad on the backhand slash cut
all the way through and lacerated the
ribs on the other Edge it cut the spine
in half the balance of the blade makes
it very wieldable in combat your weapon
will kill thank you all right Neil you
ready ready let's do this
[Music]
okay this is heavier compared to Dan's
blade but the edges are sharp enough to
lacerate the spine all the way through
the base and the weight allows for a
power slash overall the Cinque DEA will
kill good job up next is the sharpness
test we will test both of the edges of
your Blades by delivering a strike
across these ratchet straps
Daniel first you ready yes sir let's do
this
my hand will tend to choke up all the
way to the guard this weight
distribution basically pulls the blade
away definitely the sword on both sides
is easy enough to slash through and
deliver a slice that cut through all
these ratchets your blade sir will cut
thank you good job Neil your turn you
ready ready let's do this
foreign
[Music]
really fit my hand anywhere I go it
stays right where it has to be your Edge
easily cuts through these ratchets on
both sides your blade will cut
good job right on
next up is a strength test Dave
gentlemen to test the strength of your
weapon I'm going to chop into this ice
block four times with each edge of your
sword Dan you're up are you ready yes
sir okay
foreign
well I don't see any chipping or warping
so the edge held up very nicely that
guard is so lean that as I'm striking
the blade wants to turn in my hand okay
but
that did a good job nice and done
so Neil your turn you ready ready
[Music]
now the other side
[Music]
this is heavy
you see the Cinco days with the multiple
Fullers and the purpose of that is to
take that mass out of it it's not
balanced badly because you've got really
thick Tang on there
I see no damage I can't feel
any rolling so it held up beautifully
nicely done thank you
Dan Neal the judges have completed their
deliberation but in this Arena of
competition there can only be one forged
and fire champion
[Music]
Neil congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
Dan unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut Neil you picked a hell of a
way to tell the world that you're here
congratulations you are the forest and
fire champion and we'll be receiving
that check for ten thousand dollars what
are you feeling right now it's
overwhelming great job
my son is going to be ecstatic that I
won and we've been watching this show on
the couch last season for to me being on
it forges and fire Champion that's me
so crazy
[Music]
the wind and Firewheel
a rare and unique Chinese weapon the
Wind and Fire Wheels were
multifunctional tools utilized in
martial arts dating back over 500 years
approximately one foot in diameter the
wheels featured a sturdy wrapped grip
along with short but lethal protruding
blades those trained in the use of the
weapon were highly specialized needing
precise movements to execute blocking
thrusting and slashing Maneuvers in
Chinese mythology the Wind and Fire
Wheels were wielded by the god Nissan
have been popularized in the video game
Dynasty Warriors
Lane Smith's to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do I will
take your rings and deliver slashes and
thrusts on this big carcass Rebel here
first you ready more than ready
[Music]
extra
all right
I like the construction here it's Unique
I've never seen this done before it
makes it very sturdy but it adds a
little more weight to it it makes siding
it a little bit more difficult but yet
once you get going you're winning fire
will kill thank you good job
all right Chuck your turn you ready I'm
ready
foreign
critical
first up it's obvious
problem here is you lost the blade with
the welts that you have here it broke
that's why you have other blades to help
out with a fight your blades are wicked
sharp because they're so much lighter
the cuts are deeper and sharper because
your damage is not catastrophic it will
kill
next up the strength test Dave
how to test the strength and overall
construction of your Wind and Fire Rings
I'll be attacking our bamboo wushu dump
Rebel you're up first you ready
definitely
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay so right off Rebel those points are
wicked they are nice and sharp and
strong there's a lot of weight to these
blades but I think your construction
technique is brilliant nicely done thank
you all right Chuck you ready yep okay
foreign
lost another one
they feel good they're light they're
fast they're sharp but they're coming
apart
so check the bottom line is with this
kind of damage I can't safely continue
to test these I understand all right
Chuck now we have a vote of no
confidence from the judges to move
forward in this testing for that reason
I have to ask you to please leave the
forge
thanks
well Rebel this is a competition where
the best blade wins and your pair of
Apocalypse rings have definitely put you
on top congratulations you are a new
forest and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10 for
ten thousand dollars good job brother
[Applause]
I am a forged fire champion and it feels
really great although I'm very proud of
Chuck for pushing through and being a
real fighter I didn't want to win like
this but I've learned that with a little
Ingenuity and a little crazy you can
turn the impossible into the possible
and totally win this
foreign
the rooster head French Pioneer sword
[Music]
the rooster head Pioneer sword was a key
utility tool for French military
engineers known as sappers during the
19th century the weapon was a jack of
all trades featuring a sawback essential
for clearing brush and building for
scenes and a sharp clip Point lethal and
hand-to-hand combat
most notable is the weapon's Pummel
featuring a decorative Gaelic rooster
The Unofficial symbol of France
representing vigilance hope and Triumph
this iconic weapon can be seen in the
video game Mount And Blade warband
Napoleonic Wars
all right blades Vince your blades look
lovely but are they deadly I'm going to
take your weapons deliver some lethal
cuts and slashes on this goat carcass
it's time to find out they're ready for
a cockfight or they're gonna play
chicken
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
talking about your sword here it's
beautiful looking it's a heavy sword but
that lends itself to deliver very deep
Cuts with every swing and more
importantly
it will keel
all right Kate your turn so you ready
yes sir
foreign
[Music]
here your handle construction fits
perfectly in my hand now your Edge is
pristine no glints no Rollings
whatsoever and most importantly it'll
kill
all right gentlemen welcome to the
strength test the log chop
now to test the strength and overall
durability of your blades I'll be
chopping on this log all right Stephen
you're up first you ready for this let's
do it
all right first off Steven nice job on
the castings they're nicely done your
handle is about an inch too long
it allows my hand to travel around a lot
your blade took no damage whatsoever
good job thanks
all right Kade you're up next you ready
yes sir
[Music]
foreign
Kade your blade good condition
no rolls no chips still sharp as it was
when I started good job
all right blade Smith this is the
sharpest test the Scarecrow saw and
slice
to test the sawbacks on your weapon I'll
be sewing to the wooden dowels then I'll
test the Edge by cutting the watermelon
and the sugar cane bundle
Stephen you're up first you ready let's
do it
[Music]
all right Stephen let's talk about your
sawback here once it gets started it
starts to saw it works it's a functional
saw back in there you're able to dig
into the dowel your Edge is sharp no
issues cutting on the watermelon and the
weight alone is gonna just chop that
whole thing off overall sir it'll cut
thank you
all right Kate your turn you ready yes
sir
foreign
[Applause]
saw back these teeth are sharp even at
the start it already digs in a couple of
slices in there it's already digging
right into the wooden double
your Edge no issues whatsoever because
of the watermelon and cuts the rest of
the sugar King bundles overall sir
thank you
all right blade Smith's the weapons
tests are complete and the judges
literally had to weigh the details the
new Fortune fire Champion is
Kate congratulations you are the forged
and fire Champion Stephen your blade is
two pounds heavier than Cade's blade
making it less wieldy additionally your
handle is a little bit out of proportion
with the blade and it's for that reason
that you cannot beat the forge of fire
Champion okay congratulations you are
the forged and fire champion and that is
a title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel right
now
cock-a-doodle-doo
good job my friend you made a fine
rooster headed French Pioneer sword come
on forward and Shake our hands
I am super psyched right now I am so
proud of myself and I thank God that I
had this opportunity I got to keep
working hard and keep on trying to climb
that ladder you know 10 grand is college
funds
foreign
originating in the 1500s the Jumanji
Yari was carried by Japanese soldiers
known as the ashigaru these peasant foot
soldiers relied on the long-shafted
spear for its reach and versatility and
combat using the weapon's double-edged
crossbars to disarm and pull mounted
samurai from their horses ashigaru could
then employ the razor-sharp central
blade to fatally skewered the Fallen
enemy and all from a comfortable
distance today video game enthusiasts
can unleash the Jumanji yari's
devastating capabilities in the game
shadow fight 2. the Yari with its long
handle and multi-pronged spear makes it
a trifecta of points and edges in a
deadly weapon to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do I will take
your Yari and deliver multiple slashes
thrust on his picarcus but you're up
first you ready oh I'm ready
foreign
Jesus
alright for what let's talk about your
yachty here we felt that it had very
good balance to it that on the initial
slash right here it dug in into flesh
then it hit the spine the transference
of energy hit a weak spot into your
handle over here but it still had a
secondary cut all the way through I
would consider your blade a Kill
thank you it was mine mine was beautiful
well made
and some wood grain just you know
who I your weapons suffered a
catastrophic failure now that's bad
however you're not out of this
competition yet Jacob your Yari still
must perform in this kill test let's see
what happens
foreign
[Applause]
Jacob let's talk about your yachty in
the initial swing instead of being able
to cut cleanly with this part to cut
through this got in the way with the
angle that it had but let's talk about
these particular blades they are sharp
enough to penetrate into the pig carcass
the thrust is really devastating and
very deep into that your handle
Construction
it stayed true no issues at all overall
your weapon will kill thank you sir
my Yari held up and I'm just
cute
the blades of your Yari were beautifully
constructed the overall weapon was very
elegant however your shaft broke in our
first test and we cannot move forward in
this competition because that is a
catastrophic weapon failure and I have
to ask you to please leave the forge
Jacob you are the forced and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
you feel right now
that I can actually come out here at 19
and compete with serious knife makers
okay sir really I would have liked to
beat fuad in a different way but I'm a
fortune fire Champion ten thousand
dollars
it's awesome
[Music]
the zande spear oh boy one of the
deadliest weapons used by the zande
tribes of central Africa the zande spear
was used for fighting his Wells for
hunting known throughout history as
conquering Warriors the zande exhibited
unmatched skills on the battlefield
affixed to a wooden shaft the spear was
suitable for throwing and attacking from
long distances but his thrusting ability
made it just as effective as a close
combat weapon the sharp upper and lower
tines multiple spikes inflicted deadly
wounds both upon entry and exit from the
victim's body the zande's lethal use of
the spear can be seen highlighted in the
game Deadliest Warrior
bladesmiths I will take your Sunday
Spear and deliver killing blows on this
ballistic stuff
Drew you're up first you ready let's
make those intestines out testings all
right let's do that I like that
[Music]
right now I'm about to hear Doug say it
will heal and that's the only thing I'm
here for
to help me out today please welcome back
RJ markaida he will have the pleasure of
wielding your zombie spear
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it feels very good in the hand it
lacerates deep when we thrust this into
the chest cavity Into the Heart on its
way out not only does it take some skin
with it but it also took out some ribs
your times right here from the side
entry the spear went all the way through
and on its way out it took everything
that was in its path but there is one
issue as you can see your tip right here
broke off
but other than that this is a weapon
that is deadly and it will kill thank
you
all right Jason your turn you ready I
know it all cut
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Jason the balance of your
weapon feels good when it penetrated
into the chest cavity it hit a rib and
broke it in half got into the heart and
there was no Edge damage on your tip all
these hooks right here did what it's
supposed to do into the abdomen ripped
everything out even the Barb and the
beautiful thing about this is
it will kill
that's what I wanted to hear
say hello to my little friend here
today we're going to test the overall
strength and construction of your zande
Spears by well we're going to fire him
out of this cannon into this wood block
wall
now I'm not concerned about what your
Spears do to the wall I want to see how
well your Spears survive the wall Drew
you're up first are you ready no well
we're gonna do it anyway let's do it
foreign
despite the fact that you did lose a
little bit of your tip in the kill test
didn't have any effect going into that
block wall matter of fact you sunk all
the way down here very impressive your
shaft is fine nothing loosened up
nothing cracked your spear head is still
solid overall
survives very good thank you
so Jason what are you thinking thinking
let's make splinters
that's a problem
oh God no
I'm seeing it hang up a bit on the
barrel and my heart just absolutely
sinks
Jason we've got a big problem here the
parameters that we set for these weapons
are for testing purposes because your
blade didn't meet the inch and a half
parameter with a circular cross section
we cannot fit the shaft of your weapon
down the barrel of our testing apparatus
here and because we can't test it evenly
and fairly with Drew's blade I have to
ask you to please leave the forge
this was absolutely worst case scenario
I'm proud that I got this far but I'm
incredibly disappointed
well Drew in a competition where
attention to detail is just as critical
as craftsmanship you are the fortune
fire champion and we'll be collecting a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
oh how do you feel right now
I'm 18 year old and I'm the fortune fire
Champion what what just happened well I
think the best blade just won my friend
come over here and Shake our hands oh
didn't want to win this way but I won
and that's kind of all that matters I
started bladesmithing seriously because
of the show I learned all that I had to
learn to make it here and I just won
this this is the dream
oh my God man
[Music]
Blackbeard's Infamous Cutlass
foreign
among the most notorious pirates of the
18th century Blackbeard terrorized
Caribbean and Atlantic Merchant shipping
with his trademark Cutlass in hand its
short but thick curved blade featured a
razor sharp edge that was ideal for
hacking and slashing during Close
Quarters combat while seizing small
vessels in his legendary battle with
Captain Robert Maynard in 1718
Blackbeard's Cutlass broke Maynard's
sword in half with a single blow
today Blackbeard's menacing presence and
expert swordmanship can still be seen in
the video game Assassin's Creed 4 Black
Flag
bladesmiths to test a lethality of your
Cutlass I'm going to inflict lethal
wounds on these ballistic dummies
Jason you're up first you ready I sure
hope so Doug let's do this
all right Jason you got a very big
handle here but at least it's got the
swells it's got an indexing to where I
hold on to it I can tell where the edge
is the weight that you have in this
weapon is so light and sense that I can
wield it even around here you've got the
clavicle into the ribs all the way
through the lungs and definitely it will
kill all I ever wanted to hear made my
day Seth you're up next you ready get
some
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people
all right Seth your sword is forward
heavy without a balance coming back I
don't know sure it's gonna hurt more the
dummies are mine but your weapon sir
will kill thank you
this has to strength and durability of
your swords I'll be chopping through
these bones and then attacking that Peg
Leg now remember this test is not about
what your blades do to these targets
it's about what these targets can do to
your blades
testing you're up are you ready nope
[Music]
the balance of your weapon
is really nice which is surprising
because you've made a two-handed Cutlass
your blade held up very well except for
the one little chip and it's not even
chip to roll so it didn't blow out it's
a good job thank you Dave all right Seth
are you ready yes sir
foreign
first up
this thing's a beast it is probably a
pound heavier than your competitor's
sword
your blade I mean I can run my finger to
inhale down this I can see a couple of
glinting spots but it really didn't take
any damage
[Music]
all right bladesmiths let's find out if
there's any Edge left this is the Rope
Cut and pirate sale slash to test the
edge of your Cutlass I will cut this
rope which will raise the sail and then
I will slash the sail
this is all about what your sword will
do to the sailing rope
Chase are you up first ready yes sir
[Music]
all righty Jason your Edge cut through
the Rope easily and cuts with every part
that the edge met on this Pirate's sail
overall sir your sword will come
awesome Seth how you feeling
good let's go let's do this
[Music]
all right Seth what are the chances you
find out very dull spot on the first cut
on the Rope but on the second cut it
found another spot that was sharp but on
the sale working a heavy sword like this
affects my cuts
Jason Seth the judges have tested your
weapons and they've made a final
decision a new forged and fire Champion
is
Jason
congratulations you're the new Forge and
fire champion
Seth unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
[Music]
Jason congratulations you are our new
Fords and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a bundle of
bullion that's worth 10 grand how you
feeling right now
come on that's incredible Fortune fire
champion
[Music]
Spike Shield
dating back to prehistoric times The
Shield is the oldest form of protection
designed to block attacks from weapons
like Spears swords axes or arrows over
time they have varied greatly in size
and construction using materials such as
steel wood animal hide and even turtle
shells used primarily as a defense
weapon The Shield can also be used to
attack by punching an opponent with
either its face or Rim sometime around
the Middle Ages spikes were Incorporated
adding an extra level of brutality to
its design the long steel Spike could
deliver deadly blows oftentimes
immediately disemboweling the attacker
the most notable spiked Shields today
can be seen in the popular video game
series Skyrim
gentlemen between the 13th and the 16th
century spiked shields were commonly
used by infantry to protect from swords
Spears and arrows I'm going to fire
three bolts from a crossbow to test each
of your Shields if your Shield is strong
it should deflect the arrow Ilia you're
up you ready yes I am
foreign
I can see where the bolts hit Ilia small
impact there here and right there
nothing that would have been threatened
The Man Behind this Shield so that's
very well done
Michael you're up you ready I think so
let's do this all right
well Michael I can see where one hit
give a bit of a dimple
one impacted somewhere on the center
boss you could actually hear it
[Music]
and though there are some cosmetic
issues with your Shield
it's certainly held up to the strength
test
so well done thank you Doug
blade Smiths this is the Keel test
with your Shield I will take four hits
on this ballistics dummy that's wearing
chainmail you're up are you ready yes I
am
The Shield feels good in the hand I can
maneuver in different ways not only to
protect but also to attack
now let's see how much damage it did
The Killing blows right here where it
penetrated all the way that's to the
sternum and into the lung
in
that is
in the belly that goes all the way into
this ballistic dummy
your shield and the spike
will keel
Mike it's your turn you ready all right
uh Mike your Spike's a little bit loose
let's see how it goes in the test we'll
see
oh
Mike it feels good in the hand you can
strike with the edges
you can accompany it with the other hand
it moves well the spike did hold up now
let's see how much damage we did all
right
your Spike definitely penetrated on both
punctures right here probably where the
diaphragm is and in the abdomen right
here all the way through
your Shield
will kill
thank you late Spitz this is the
sharpness test I will attach your Shield
to this mechanical device I will then
release your Shield to see if it'll
puncture the steel drum if your spike is
sharp it should go in easily if not well
you may just Dent the drum
you know you're up are you ready yes I
am three two one engaging
well Ilya your Spike went cleanly
through the drum and all the way out I
don't see any problems or any
deformations on your Spike so it held up
very well good job thank you
Mike you're up are you ready oh yeah
let's do this
[Music]
and in three two one engaging
well Mike
your Spike went all the way through got
stuck a little bit came out cleanly but
I do not see any damage to your Spike
good job sir thank you
judges have scrutinized your work and
they've made a final decision about
which of you is the forged and fire
champion who will receive a check for
ten thousand dollars
Ilya
you are the forced Empire champion
congratulations thank you Mike your
Shield did not make the cut please
surrender your Shield
thank you John this is a fantastic
experience I think I performed very well
so as much as I would have liked to win
this still feels like a victory
Ilya congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars
thank you
the way that all works together I mean
just fantastic piece I think I'm fairly
satisfied with the end result I might
not often show it but trust me I am
proud
the prize money is already pretty much
spent on student loans and my
girlfriend's education and astrophysics
I'm the fortune fire champion and it
feels pretty good
the Lynch next sword
[Music]
created by Emperor Maximilian the first
in the 15th century the Lance connects
were a deadly mercenary Force armed with
Pike's swords and crossbows
the most battle proven Lance connect
mercenaries were armed with massive
two-handed swords
these imposing blades featured parrying
lugs above the guard to deflect enemy
attacks earning double the pay of their
peers these garishly dressed Swordsmen
of Fortune would rush headlong into
enemy Pikes in an effort to disrupt
their opponent's formations today you
can see The lanschneck Sword and the hit
mobile strategy game dominations
bladesmiths the two-handed German
national swords a big sword so expecting
big damage I will take your sword and
deliver slashes thrust and chops on this
wild boar carcass tidy up first you
ready yes I am let's do this
just
dance
all right Todd first up your handle
construction it's comfortable to hold on
to you have a very thick and wide and
stout Edge so it's a chopper not a
slicer the big issue I have with this is
that it's a heavy sword but despite its
weight it will kill it's
all right DJ it's your turn you ready
yep
[Music]
[Music]
DJ is talking about your sword here
it's even heavier than the other side
the tip you have over here is wide the
first thrust went in the second one
couldn't and I tried
the one thing it did was break its back
a Thrust like that in a broken back like
that
will kill all right
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test I'm going to test the
overall construction of your blade I'll
be both stabbing and chopping into the
steel plate
all right Todd you're up first you ready
yes
all right Todd you took some pretty good
rolls these rolls are fairly deep but uh
it held up nice and done
all right DJ you ready for this yeah
no board
[Music]
all right
foreign
this weapon is heavy
look at that balance point so far
forward keeping that tip up
is brutal you've got a really really
super Stout Edge and honestly it held up
quite well there are some rolls here
where it connected but uh the weapons
are still solid
it's a strong blade thank you all right
gentlemen your blades are still in one
piece now let's see if they still have
an edge to test that edge I'll be
cutting through this cane
Todd you're up you ready yes okay
hear that it sings It's like a tuning
fork
[Music]
all right Todd so let's talk about your
uh singing sword here
you definitely have a sharp edge here
sharp sword made good cuts hold on thank
you thank you
all right DJ you ready are you ready
that's a big one
I'm ready
foreign
[Music]
along that edge
on the first cut as soon as I hit the
dull part it just starts pushing stuff
over
did a good job putting it together
but it's just not sharp enough to cut
[Music]
Todd DJ you've both done an incredible
amount of work to bring these massive
swords back for our final round of
competition but there can only be one
forged and fire Champion that champion
is
foreign
Todd congratulations you are the new
forged and fire Champion DJ
unfortunately your sword didn't make the
cut please surrender your blade
my biggest regret is I should have spent
more time on the edge
I did my best and I didn't want to build
something that was going to snap and I
definitely did that
Todd congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check ten
thousand dollars good job thank you
thank you very much
please present your blade to the judges
I'm a little surprised you know I still
like a surreal kind of thing I've proven
what I've come to prove that I'm capable
that I'm still skilled and I'm thrilled
that I was up to the challenge I feel so
good I don't know how to feel
[Music]
ardish
sweet
vicious and menacing the berdish was a
favorite of Eastern European infantry
soldiers during the 16th and 17th
centuries its large crescent-shaped ax
head measured nearly two feet at the
edge and could cleave through flesh and
Bone specialized soldiers called
strodsey would use the bardice's pole to
balance their muskets for firing from a
distance then switch to their acts
during melee combat though rare in
American pop culture you can experience
the bardetia's savagery on the virtual
Battlefield of the game Chivalry
medieval warfare alright bladesmiths
this is the kill test
find out how lethal your weapon is I
will take your bardish and deliver
lethal chops on this big carcass
John you're up first you ready let's do
it let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
nice head on brother
all right John's talking about your
bardish here I love the swells by
putting these welds right there it
allows me to adjust my hand and get a
good grip every time I move it around
your blade right here is razor sharp
cuts through spine bones and thick flesh
overall sir your Mardis
will kill I got something to show you oh
sure kill tests
oh it will kill
good job I was hoping to kill because
I'd do that I did that and a good job
all right Michael your turn you got
anything to show me nope all right you
ready for this yes sir let's do this
nice
[Music]
all right Michael this is at least
around 11 pounds all forward wheat I
waste so much energy in recoiling that
could be used in attack but overall sir
your buddies
will kill yeah
Smith welcome to the strength test the
stump thump and steer smash to test the
strength and durability of your bar
dishes as well as their overall
construction I'll be chopping
mercilessly into these logs and cleaving
that steer skull in half remember this
is all about what happens to your
vardish and not what happens to the
wooden bone John you're up first you
ready let's do it
nice
awesome well John you're uh bardish it's
got a nice weight to it
I'm not a huge fan of these undulations
in the handle because I want to be able
to move my hands around
I'm looking at the edge it held up
beautifully everything's still straight
and tight good job thank you
Michael you're up next are you ready oh
yeah hope you ate your Wheaties
oh boy
all right
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
well Michael first things first this
thing is heavy it's a beast but uh
everything is still tight there's no
Motion in it even after all of that
chopping and smashing of skulls The Edge
held up really well so well done that's
awesome yeah up next is the sharpness
test and for that I give you today
all right gentlemen now unlike the
strength test this is all about your
blades do to the Target so take a one
shot right down the middle trying to
split those watermelon put half in one
bucket half in the other all right
Johnny you ready let's do it okay
[Music]
nice
all right John it feels good it's got a
good balance to it the shape of this is
really nice The Cutting Edge curved like
that cut through the watermelon
beautifully sharp Weapon It's nice
enough thanks all right Michael you're
up are you ready bring out the Beast
okay
hahaha
well right off it's definitely sharp but
it weighs a ton I like the design of
this but build strong doesn't
necessarily mean build heavy
John Mike you bladesmiths have engaged
in one of our most difficult
competitions however only one of you can
be the forged fire champion
that champion is
John congratulations you're our new
Forester fire Champion Mike
unfortunately your weapon didn't make
the cut please surrender your weapon
my experience here was definitely a
challenge coached me to my limits I
learned a lot
I might not be the torch and fire
Champion but I still feel like I'm
walking away a winner John
congratulations you're the new forged
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for how much and
Graham please present your bardish to
the judges this is the most mentally
physically emotionally stressful time
also the best time in my life
origin fire Champion I'm super excited
to get home and tell my wife about the
great news and now next thing coming up
I'm gonna be having a baby boy so I mean
this is wonderfully here thank God
the Executioner sword
the Executioner sword performed its
bloody work in 16th century Central
Europe unlike combat swords this lethal
blade features a straight double-edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip perfect
for swiftly chopping off the heads of
criminals this deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather than the
ax since it allowed the victim to meet
his end in a dignified kneeling position
rather than laying face down with his
head on the Block while The
Executioner's sword fell out of use in
the early 18th century this gruesome
sword is still wielded in the 2019 video
game mordhaus
basements welcome to the Keel test
The Executioner's sword that word alone
just gives you visions of decapitated
heads so to find out what kind of lethal
damage your executioner sword can do
I'll deliver some while lethal blows on
this ballistics dummy
Nathan is it time it's time have fun
[Music]
awesome crap
just a little off the top
all right Ethan first stop this is a
heavy Beast it is so forward heavy that
you eat two hats to control that now
your handle construction is smooth I'll
give you that but it also feels a little
bit rounded over here where it actually
gives me much more control sideways than
it does this way but overall your
weapons sir filled with Keel awesome
all right Gunner your turrets are you
ready absolutely let's do this
[Music]
all right Gunners talk about your
executioner sword over here your blade
right here has a finer grind so it makes
it a little bit lighter and the edge
that you have here when it came to that
skull just glided into that overall sir
your execution your sword it'll kill
thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the skull and bone chop
now to test the overall construction of
your blades as well as how they feel
while they're being used I'll be
chopping into these skulls and that
nasty giraffe bone
Nathan you're up are you ready yes sir
have fun
[Music]
thank you
holy draft
all right Nathan so right off man this
thing is heavy but once you get it
moving it's going but controlling it's
tough having said that your Edge hella
beautifully it's still just as sharp as
when I started which is pretty darn
sharp so good job on that thanks I like
sharp things
ready
what if I said no I'd say you don't
watch this so much do you exactly
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right so gonna write off lighter
blade easier to control a lot of that
has to do with the fact you've got more
handle here
now your blade it's got some compacting
on the edges but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge it's still for
Lonnie sharp nicely done thank you sir
all right blade Smiths this is the
sharpest test the Jackfruit and water
jug slice
Ethan you're up first you ready yes sir
have fun all right let's do this
[Music]
still Sharp
all right Nathan as far as the downward
chop it's a very clean cut easy no
resistance whatsoever now when I was
cutting as soon as I met the resistance
of the water it kind of rolled on my
hand
but anything that it did have contact
with it was able to cut overall sir your
weapon you will cut it thank you
all right go to your turn so you ready
yes sir I am let's do this
foreign
[Music]
ER the handle construction you have here
is wide and oh void enough to where when
I hold on to it I can really tell where
the edge is and it's much easier to
control a blade like this in the slice
you can see that cuts nicely overall sir
your weapon it will cut thank you
the boys Miss only one of you can leave
here with the title of Fortune fire
champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars now the judges
discussed your blades and they made a
final decision
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Gunner congratulations now Nathan you
fought hard man but unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut I'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you very much
congratulations
well I'm gonna have to find a different
way to take my wife to go see Bigfoot
but we're still gonna go
well Gunner that makes you the forge of
fire Champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you appreciate it
guys
[Applause]
I just won forged in fire feeling good
well I mean I've never thought I would
make it this far from day one I don't
necessarily think that I'm a better
Smith than any of these other guys that
just worked out in my favor today as far
as the money uh after football season
ends my wife and I will probably take a
long weekend somewhere
foreign
[Music]
rising to popularity in Italy during the
16th and 17th centuries the skiavona
became the trusted weapon for
Mercenaries recruited to guard the
Venetian head of state the swords Long
Blade included multiple Fullers to
lighten its weight while its straight
double edge made it conducive for deadly
thrusts and cuts the most eye-catching
feature of this blade was its basket
Hilt with multiple pieces of Steel that
intertwined to protect the hand from
brutal slashes its attractive yet deadly
qualities are why the skiavona can still
be found today in popular games such as
Assassin's Creed alright bladesmiths as
you can see I'm still recovering from an
injury so to be my arm today and have
the pleasure of testing your weapon I'd
like to bring back one of my favorite
students my brother RJ marcaida
foreign
the one issue I have about your handle
right here it did cause some issues by
rubbing against the thumb right there
but more importantly it is a sharp blade
for slashing and thrusting it will kill
cool
Jeff you ready let's do this
[Music]
oh
one right here okay all right Jeff a
little bit on the inside of your basket
Hilt right there it did dig in into his
knuckles
but overall for talking about a killing
blade here with good balance and the
kind of Destruction it did it will kill
your job
all right bladesmiths next stop it's a
strength test then
contest your shivona's basket and blade
I'm gonna punch into these terracotta
parts and then chop into these virtual
orgs and remember it's not what happens
to the valves or the wood it's what
happens to your blade
you're up first you ready my shiavona is
definitely ready
foreign
once I started chopping into that log it
was just going the whole time there is a
tiny little deformation right there it's
pretty narrow
you can hear it you know
all in all it's sharp and it's a good
Chopper nicely done yeah
all right Jeff you're up you ready let's
do this
well Jeff
this is a heck of a chopper it's got a
lot of forward weight it's a little bit
on the heavy side but not too much in
general and in total it held up really
well nice job thank you
all right gentlemen this is our
sharpness test a rope and sandbag slash
what I'll do to test the edges of your
blade is slice the Rope releasing the
sandbag then cut the bag what we want to
see are good clean cuts through the rope
and clean cuts through the bag Brad
you're up first you ready ready
oh
okay Brett on the cuts pass through the
rope with no problem this blade has a
beautiful Edge a fine cutter excellent
well done thank you
Jeff you ready let's get it on all right
let's do this
I think right now we're almost dead even
couldn't be any closer
all right Jeff what I like about your
blade is it's look this industrial look
it's cool it didn't slice all the way
through the bag but it cuts very cleanly
nicely done thank you
Brad Jeff you were both extraordinary
weaponsmiths but there can only be one
forged and fire champion
Jeff congratulations you are a newest
forged and fire Champion Brad
unfortunately your weapon did not make
the cut Brad this is probably the most
difficult Hilt design we have sent any
of our Smiths home to do and you both
did a really nice job and we had to look
at the finest of details and that that
rolled Edge you took in the strength
test
that's why we've got to send you home
Brad please surrender your weapon
I did the best that I could and I put
every single bit of effort into my blade
and Jeff I hope we become friends
forever I definitely have a lot to learn
from you
and I'm just so close to being the
champion
just you are the new forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
my heart's pounding out of my chest this
is what I came here to do please present
your weapon to the judges I feel
freaking awesome this is everything this
is what I wanted
perfect
I heard Brendan might have called me
Magic Mike but I'll tell you what the
magic who's floating baby the magic is
floating
the headhunter's ax
the Headhunter ax is both a tool and a
weapon of the native igora tribe who
hail from the mountains of the
Philippines featuring a sharp Spike on
one side that is used to pierce Shields
and armor it also contained a wide
lethal ax head on the other side
designed to swiftly decapitate enemies
in the heat of battle an intimidating
weapon tribes would display the heads of
their victims to strike fear into their
enemies the legacy of this deadly act
lives on today and can be seen in the
video game State of Decay breakdown
ladies Miss welcome to the Keel test
the igorot Headhunters ax a weapon that
I've always fantasized about because
it's very close to my Filipino Heritage
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your headhunter's ex will do I will take
your weapon and deliver some lethal
blows on this ballistics dummy Jordan
are you ready because I am so let's do
this
right now I'm pretty intimidated if that
Spike hits the backbone or the skull or
anything like that I think it's snap
right off
all right
all right Jordan let's talk about your
Headhunters ax here your edges here are
very sharp with every strike it dug in
very deep into this ballistics dummy the
spike you have here even digging into
the skull did not bend it feels good in
the hand and more importantly sir
heal thank you
all right Jesse you're up next are you
ready I'm ready let's do this
I'm feeling nervous I'm worried about my
ax head flying off the socket because
those bones are dense you know going
into a human skull is not an easy task
s
oh he head-buttered me
all right Jesse let's talk about your
headhunter's ax over here first up the
handle construction somebody did some
research in some Polynesian tattoos
there looks good and it feels good in
the hand your edges here penetrated very
deep into this ballistics dummy now your
Spike here not only did it penetrate the
skull but it also cut it and it stayed
true overall sir your headhunter's ex
little Keel thanks Dad
all right gentlemen Welcome to our
strength test the bamboo and skull chop
now you get two totally different
materials here you got the springy
bamboo that likes to bounce things back
in the skulls at like the break edges so
we're going to test both ends and the
overall construction of your Headhunters
axes during your smile as you're up
first how about that yes sir okay let's
do it
ah
[Music]
Jordan nice job take a breath now
everything held up nicely everything's
tight doesn't look like anything moved
your edges are still sharp I mean the
fact that you made this thing light
tough and in Damascus in three days
that's a heck of a feat good job thank
you
all right Jesse how you feel after
seeing that not good not good it'll be
fine okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
man
all right Jesse on the plus side
it felt great in the hand
and your edges held up just fine
but just all the shock wave from the
force of those strikes split the handle
almost in half so definitely not going
to be able to continue testing with this
weapon
well Jesse we absolutely hate to see
that happen phenomenal job on your blade
itself but unfortunately you had a
catastrophic failure when your handle
broke and for that reason we can no
longer continue testing your weapon I'm
gonna have to ask you to please leave
the forge
I felt a little heartbroken seeing
something that I put so much work into
would be broke but I came onto this
competition just to prove that I can
compete with some of the best blade
Smiths out there and I know I've already
accomplished that so I still feel like
I'm going home a winner
well Jordan you survived the test your
blade came out on top so congratulations
you are the forge and fire champion and
there's a ten thousand dollar check
waiting for you outside that door very
well done
I just won force of fire I don't really
know what to say right now Sasquatch is
kind of my mascot and so I feel like
that's a Sasquatch worthy Acts
foreign
yeah one of the most popular weapons
during the Middle Ages the falshin was a
commoner sword that found widespread use
both on and off European battlefields a
thick and heavy sword falcian's featured
either a straight or slightly curved
blade with a single sharp edge making it
well suited for the vicious Close
Quarters combat of medieval Wars
eventually this Broad and deadly hacking
weapon transitioned from a combat
sidearm to a hunting sword like other
historic European weapons of its time
although the falshin disappeared from
battlefields and hunting grounds its
Legacy virtually lives on in video games
like Warhammer vermintide 2 and Dark
Souls 3.
all right bladesmiths this is the Keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according to its
historic design I will try to cut this
big carcass in half when you're up first
you ready for this absolutely
one and done well now all right Wayne
your file Sean is beautiful it is sharp
we've cut through the spine and all the
way through the pig it's a little bit
heavier for a one-handed weapon but it
is well balanced overall sir it will
kill awesome
all right Mark your turn sir are you
ready let's give it a shot
all right marks talk about your fouchon
here it's a nice lighter blade your
edges are sharp enough to cut through
spine but the problem I have here is
your guard
your edges here are not rounded they dig
in right here where the thumb is but
your blade sir it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
I'll be attacking our armored dummy here
this test is not about what your swords
do to that armor it's about what that
armor does to your swords Wayne you're
up you ready
let's do it
[Music]
oh cool
first off when your Edge has taken some
small chips some small rolls but it's
very very minor damage there's still a
sharp edge here all in all it held up
beautifully all right thank you
so Mark I gotta ask what's with the
shirt I got married in this shirt
actually uh it's you know it's my Formal
Wear all right while you're ready for
the test I am okay
okay
foreign
so first off the blade is still solid
you did get some minor rolling but the
blade still has an edge
down here is the problem your guard
these edges are not just Square they're
sharp
but the blade held up good job thank you
foreign
now it's time to find out if there's any
sharpness left to your weapons to test
the edge of your weapon I'm going to cut
through this Gauntlet of sandbags
Wayne you're first you ready for this oh
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
your weapon is sharp on every swing it
cuts and slashes nicely and most
importantly aside from being smurfed
it look
s
all right Mark's your turn you ready I
am let's have fun
[Music]
[Music]
all right Mark as you can see on both
these bags it cut deeply on the second
bag on the swing back over there it must
have hit a dull spot it did Rip parts of
the bag but it didn't cut all the way in
but overall it is sharp and it will cut
Wayne Mark was a tight decision
[Music]
Wayne congratulations you're the forged
and fire Champion Mark unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut please
surrender your weapon and leave the
forge
from start to finish this whole thing
was a learning process for me and I
honestly think I have gotten years worth
of experience and feedback in just a
short time great job this experience was
life-changing
Wayne congratulations you are one bad
ass Everlasting bladesmith and our new
forest and fire Champion good job
brother yeah yes
please at this time present your blade
to our judges
so I did it man I wanted it next for me
I'm gonna get back on the same thing
that's led me to this point which is
just non-stop going Full Throttle I'm
just gonna keep pushing I'm Gonna Keep
Me better and better
[Music]
this is byhander
the Spy hander which means two-hander in
German was a massive sword wielded by
Swiss and German mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching to
over six feet in length this by-hander
was a long sword featuring an extended
grip in Broad Garden as European armies
employed more Pikes and pole arms on the
battlefield the zyhander emerged as a
counter weapon this enormous sword was
used to break up Pike formations by
cutting spear ends and opening up holes
in Enemy Lines due to its size the Spy
hander was only wielded by the biggest
and most audacious soldiers if these
soldiers survived charges into enemy
Spears they would often be paid double
for their substantial risk the
zweihander eventually faded from the
battlefield but survives today in games
such as Dark Souls your spy handers are
big so we came to a big open space to
test them up first the sharpness test
Dave
now the survivander was known as a
weapon of intimidation to test the
sharpness of your Edge I'm going to cut
into this bundle of sugar cane twice
once with either side
Jay you're up first are you ready as I'm
ever going to be
questions
it's got a lot of weight to it but
obviously it's plenty Sharp
nicely done thank you all right Stephen
you're up are you ready can't wait Jay's
weapon did really well cutting through
the sugar canes I'm not nervous about
mine but you know I don't know if it's
going to cut better than his his cut
real strong
[Music]
it's light it's easy to wield
that guard it's almost where it's
into you when you're swinging it
you can see it cut deep and clean it
looks like the blade held it beautifully
so nice job thank you
blade spits this yander was a weapon of
War big weapon big damage I will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
this ballistic dummy and see how much
damage your weapon can do
J up first you ready go for it let's do
this
foreign
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows but on
the thrust I was able to go in one side
and all the way on the opposite side of
the dummy
yes sir will kill
thank you
see when you're up next you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
that was brutal
okay Steve
the edge of your sword
is sharp enough to last weight all the
way into the ribs and on the power
strike that would disembowel
and ruin this person
it's the idea this sword will kill
good job thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
the zioner was often used against Pike
formations so I'm going to take yours by
handers and go against a rack of Pikes
here five times with each of your blades
and see how far I can break through
Jay you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
so after two tests Stephen and uh
they're pretty neck and neck so I feel
pretty nervous because this next test
should really determine who's going to
take home the prize
thank you
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
I don't see any damage to your Edge
nicely done thank you
all right Steve you're up do it okay
foreign
obviously it's a good cutter to actually
fit into that wood and split that right
down the middle very easy to wield
because of its lightweight but I think
we've
bent just a little bit
it's bent in two directions and there is
a crack now developing in the handle
gentlemen we've got a lot to discuss
we'll see you back at the forge I'm
concerned I had a warp in my blade so I
don't know who's going to end up with
the Wind
bladesmiths the judges have made their
final decision it's time to declare one
of you the forged and fire champion
Jay congratulations
Stephen unfortunately your sword did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
I'm disappointed I really wanted to win
but that's okay I love being at the
forge it's hot it's dirty you'll smell
funny but it is so rewarding
Jay congratulations you are the forest
and fire Champion good job
thank you how you feel right now uh I
feel like my heart's about to burst out
of my chest but most heaviest weapon
I've ever had to wield in this
competition very well balanced and a
powerful weapon too thank you and the
way you built your handle that that
tells me a lot about the way that you
make things the wood is fitted on and
then wrapped with leather with these
reinforcing pieces underneath that's the
proper way to construct it oh thank you
well Jay in exchange for that sword and
those socks and we'll be receiving that
check for ten thousand dollars when they
announced that I was the winner it felt
really good I had people tell me you
know you're good at what you do but I
always have this kind of self-doubt to
make it all the way to the end and be
the champion I'm so happy